[Music]
[Music]
do we know who did it like has anyone
ever been held responsible
not until now
this was an exciting time in the
cryptocurrency world ethereum was still
really young the dao
was essentially a venture capital
governance model that let the public
decide how their own funds would be
invested in this case they'd raised 139
million dollars worth of ether and then
things went wildly wrong
at the time the dow hack was potentially
catastrophic it sent the price of ether
crashing and it even ended up triggering
uh a fork of the cryptocurrency leading
to a new cryptocurrency called ethereum
classic one of the biggest mysteries of
crypto is who is the notorious dow
hacker the former senior editor at
forbes laura shin believes she's
identified that person while i was
working on my book my sources and i were
trying to figure it out during that time
you know i was pursuing every single
lead that came my way laura had been
working on the book for four years and
was this close to submitting the text
for final publication when one of her
sources approached her with a
development so the timing on this wasn't
great obviously because the book is
basically nearly completed one of my
sources said that they were the subject
of an investigation into the dao they
were innocent but they wanted to be able
to prove this to their government
and so they commissioned a report and
they said hey
i i know you're looking into this maybe
this information could be helpful to you
as well we took the report and we just
basically were trying to analyze how
this person was trying to cash out and
they were trying to cash out via an
exchange that didn't take customer
identifying information which is why we
couldn't just try to find somebody there
who might tell us whose name was on that
account and what they were doing was
trying to convert it into bitcoin they
actually only attempted to do that
for roughly
three months in the fall of 2016. then
they stopped
i reached out to a company called chain
analysis and then asked them to keep
following the trail
the hacker had taken the bitcoins that
they had received it was about 282
bitcoins and they were
using what's called a wasabi wallet
which is a type of mixer and what i mean
by that is that the bitcoins get mixed
together with a bunch of other people's
bitcoins and then when the mixer spits
them out on the other side it's hard to
follow the trail so previously thought
to be impossible exactly so what they
found was that on the other side the
money did go to four exchanges and at
one of the exchanges i did have a source
who was able to find out what happened
to the money that was deposited at that
exchange
that money was converted to a somewhat
obscure crypto called grin which is a
privacy coin and the money then was
withdrawn to an actual grin node the
node is basically running the software
help to keep the network alive
interestingly enough for a privacy coin
the grin node in this case had a human
readable url which was
dot grinn.toby.ai toby ai is the alias
that this person liked to use for pretty
much all of their social media accounts
and other accounts
[Music]
[Music]
10x was the name of an ico in the 2017
era it raised 80 million dollars and the
founder of that was a man named toby
hoenish ladies and gentlemen
with what certainty um
are you that the person that you've
identified and published in the article
is the dow hacker
that's my opinion based on the research
the evidence is extremely good the
people who were working with me on this
they do a lot of investigations and they
said to me laura the evidence is never
this good so they've also felt extremely
extremely confident about it so toby is
austrian he's in his mid-30s and the
time of cashing out he was living in
singapore and i actually think he
probably likely still lives there but i
i'm not 100 sure i think he's a little
bit of an energetic person i guess we
could say um his hobbies include salsa
dancing and acro yoga which is a form of
acrobatics combined with yoga
what else do we know about him it took a
little bit of digging because toby had
actually
not really participated much online in
recent years and had actually deleted
things like his reddit history however
i was able to find some old blog posts
and medium posts and also look at his
tweets from around the time of the dao
i sent him a document showing him
everything that would be said about him
in the book and gave him the opportunity
to respond and he said your your
statement and conclusion is factually
inaccurate he said that if i wanted he
could provide me more details so i
immediately wrote it back and i said yes
i would like more details and i asked
him that four times but he did not
respond after that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you